Marching for peace in Ukraine hundreds
took to the Streets of London on
Saturday urging a ceasefire and
negotiations with Russia to end the
conflict among them supporters of the
campaign for nuclear disarmament warning
that any escalation in fighting would
increase the chances of a nuclear war
many wanted to see and enter Western
military support for Ukraine it would
help if we stopped saying we'll just
give you lots more weapons until you win
the war
it's not going to happen like that you
know ukrainians are really tough
Russians are really tough and NATO is
really rich
so that's that's all the ingredients you
need for a kind of endless war well this
demonstration is one of many happening
over this weekend across Europe now for
these demonstrators arming Ukraine is
simply making things worse and
prolonging the conflict but others take
a very different approach
in the Belgian Capital many of those
marching in solidarity with Ukraine were
actually refugees from that country
[Music]
the weapons for our defense we need the
sanctions against the Russia uh we need
economical support because we defend not
only our land but we defend all
democracy world my own work is here I
want to do my best in it I want to show
people as much people as they can that
we want to survive we want normal life
we want our life back while in Berlin a
bigger protest at least 10 000 turned up
to say no to the idea of Germany arming
Ukraine we're demonstrating four Ps and
against
intervention of our government in uh in
that war that is not ours
the people that voted for those
politicians they did not know that they
will
push us into war and send weapons into
countries that are in war this is even
against our constitution
so different messages and no end in
sight to the misery inflicted on the
people of Ukraine Nadeem Barber Al
Jazeera London